well first of all ladies congratulations
on your show
stick to sports on vice tv i honestly
can watch you guys talk
all day because i leave feeling educated
of course i laugh because you two are
hilarious together
and then i want to be a better person so
i just happen to ask you i do
i know kerry's looking like possible
i'm like really okay because as a black
woman in this medium
to see other women owning their voice
and owning who they are and being
unapologetic about that
it's inspiring yeah yeah you don't think
you're firing care you're like
oh no i agree i think we get that a lot
i think that
um what jemele and i have been able to
capture with this show
is just um honestly just two friends
talking college dropout kanye what
happened to that kanye what happened to
graduation kanye the kardashians
let's just keep it all the way funky i
do believe there'll be some form of
football played
it won't look the same but there will be
i always tell people this
there's always a plan you just don't
know how it'll all shape up so i i
found jamal um at her home one day and i
brought a camera crew to her house
a camera crew to her house and i said
hey we're going to film something we
didn't know what it would be but the
idea was supposed to just be us talking
and while we were filming a really good
friend of ours said there's something
here it's very
creative i like the idea of you two
you know talking and being honest and
being unapologetic
and i think what happened was that we
knew we would work together we just
didn't know what capacity because we've
always been working together
we were at espn we would do periscopes
and we would do we've talked about this
before we would do
you know instagram lives and we would
just share our opinion and people really
um appreciated it well there were two
things that you didn't see
two women two black women um in in
theory in the same space
but while we are very much alike we're
so very different
from the way that we think about certain
issues she doesn't want to catch up on
her tacos from the way that we dress
the world does come out
[Laughter]
and i just believe that um
it is so refreshing to see what you are
there's not a lot of representation even
in 2020 there's just not a lot of
representation
it's just refreshing to see like okay
this does exist there is a space in
which we can share an opinion
and feel safe i know more than anything
work environments aren't always safe and
i feel safe working with her
i feel like she will always protect me
like i like and i'll always have her
back
in in in so many different ways whether
i'm if
we mess up and i say something wrong on
air she's like girl you know that
that's not his name you know or whatever
and vice versa and so
that just brings out the best in us and
i and i i wish everybody could have that
working environment because i know it's
new and foreign to me
there's a call to action on everybody to
find their voice in this fight
to not only just be clear on who we are
but what we choose to put out into the
world
so how did you two find your voice well
there's a
temptation to believe that finding your
voice is something that just
magically happens like poof instead i
found my voice
but i think it's it's really a
collection of experiences
it's living it's time it's wisdom it's
all of those things and then
that has to meet the moment where you
really stop caring about what people
think
and by that i don't mean that you're not
um you don't feel the responsibilities
to family and community and whatever
else is important
what it does mean is that you feel as if
it's important to speak
whatever is your truth or whatever
truths that you see that exist without
worrying about the condemnation of other
people um
and so i don't know if that's a point
that you'll arrive when you're in your
40s or if you're in your 30s or your 20s
but it it
you get to that intersection and once
you get there it's just kind of
impossible
you know to go back like i can't imagine
now going back
to any environment where i didn't feel
comfortable
and to borrow carries where it's safe
and expressing
what it is um because i've lived that
life before
and having lived that life i realized
just how unproductive
and honestly how draining that is and i
don't ever want to
kind of return to that and so you know
finding your voice
really means finding yourself because
that's what we mean by voice
everybody experiences that though so
you're not alone
and some people find their voice as
early as their 20s i think this
generation we're watching right now as
we watch these athletes
you know um on and off the court on and
off the field
they are finding their voice rapidly and
you again have to be unapologetic
and you and as jamel just said be okay
with someone saying you're wrong or
that's dumb or you have to ignore that
but that doesn't come overnight
you have to be so passionate and
determined
and and more importantly you have to
believe that you have a purpose
i think to share whatever it is that you
should be sharing if i was out here
disputing some nonsense
you know just because people people
don't believe in that and they don't buy
into that you have to believe the
the lifestyle the experience that we're
sharing because we've been through a lot
and we still don't
i honestly feel like we still save
people we have a saying like if i
haven't even said anything about you i'm
doing you a favor
that's placing mercy that's right
silence is great sometimes
i love that and july disney announced a
production deal with colin kaepernick
which includes a documentary series
at espn that will be produced by you
jamil you're
part of the team what are your thoughts
on this full circle moment considering
everything you've been through and what
can you tell us about the series
well um it's still in this infancy stage
and it's the most
unexpected but amazing opportunity i've
ever received in my career
when colin and i first started talking
it was not with the intention of me
coming on as a producer for his
incredible story
he just wanted to know the beats of what
happened between me and espn
uh because he did not want to get into
business with somebody
that could have harmed another black
person which says a lot about him and
his character
um and even though uh you know espn and
i
we certainly had our moments of
disagreement and tumultuousness
i mean the reality is i worked there 12
years i'd say 10 of them
were really good um the last two
debatable about what that was um but
that's okay
i mean when i left there i didn't leave
on bad terms i
i certainly left there with some
feelings about certain people but i
didn't leave there on bad terms i left
there with most of my relationships
completely intact
so when he called me and asked for my
opinion i was honest but i was fair
and the reality is that the disney
platform the espn platform
presents him an incredible opportunity
to tell his story the way that it
deserves to be told
um my question for him was can you get
over the fact that
espn contributed to a lot of the bad
narratives that surrounded your story
and if you can get over that part i
think you have a real opportunity
to shift the culture in a place that
needs their culture to be shifted
and i think he saw that um and i think
he understood that it wasn't just about
him um he went into it with the
intention of amplifying
other people amplifying black voices
both those that will work
on his particular story but also inside
of espn
and he's in a real unique position to do
that so
i thought even though um you know there
probably would be
some level of awkwardness there for both
of us not just for me
that the opportunity was just to
attractive and it was too big and it
meant too much
for him to pass it up and also for me i
mean
there's nothing that happened there that
would make me
pass up on the opportunity to finally
give his story what it's due
right right and it kind of it makes i
don't want to say it makes what you went
through
you know makes sense but
essentially looking down the line it's
like okay everything is working out for
our good
when it comes to the situation i have
one more question before
before i let you go i saw that you read
the book cast
on twitter
what happens when you give a book review
people just don't want to read it
somehow
you tweeted been reading isabelle
wilkerson's new book cast
and if you weren't of the opinion that
the united states wasn't nearly as
bad as nazi germany how wrong you are
can't encourage you enough to read this
masterpiece
now a lot of people didn't agree with
your take
would you like to further i know the
book is so deep and it's hard to put
all of your thoughts on twitter when it
comes to the book do you want to
elaborate a little bit more
on what you meant by that i uh
i will look kerry said it earlier and
it's true
is that part of the reason why we have
such a difficult time
discussing race in this country
resolving race in this country is
because we've lied about our history
we have run one of the greatest public
relations campaigns in the world
um people don't realize when we say that
we're the best
um you know we're the best country on
earth that's an affirmation
okay that's not a fact all right and it
isn't to say i don't love my country of
course i do but i
love my country and realize it's flaws
and one of the things that maybe people
didn't know which isabelle wilkerson
points out brilliantly in this book
and she's not the first historian to
point this out by the way our first
scholar
is that uh hitler and the nazis learned
from us and they took our jim crow's
our jim crow laws and they created the
nuremberg laws which
behaved in a similar capacity in nazi
germany during that regime i mean they
looked at our system of racial
oppression
and they were they admired it because
they
could not understand how the united
states has such
a stellar reputation in the world for
being free and being a democracy
despite the fact that right in front of
everybody they were systematically
uh brutalizing and oppressing black
people and this is
evident in any history book that you
read and it wasn't just that they copied
and admired our racism
it was also the fact that when you look
at the history of slavery which
i don't know last count lasted hundreds
of years um
you know you saw the regular brutality
murder
rape and torture of black people we did
that
it happened on our soil but the thing
that
we didn't learn that germany did was
that you have to at some point
rectify that they apologized to the jews
they sent them reparations
uh when you go to germany you know what
you don't see statues of nazis
you know what you see in america statues
of confederate leaders
traitors of this country you know i use
this example because i think it should
it says everything about
our racial history and our attempt to
justify the ugliness
um that we have brought forth john lewis
walked he marched the edmund pettus
bridge in selma alabama
for voting rights for equality he almost
died because he had his head cracked
open
edmund pettus was the leader of the
alabama ku klux klan
there's a bridge named after him john
lewis is dead that bridge is still
standing
that says everything about america so
what i wanted people to understand by me
saying that
is not that i would say that current
america is like nazi germany
i certainly wasn't trying to denigrate
or diminish or belittle
the persecution and extermination of
millions of jews which is a key
difference when you compare the
countries
they needed us to work that's really the
only difference right
but um i want people to know that
uh the reason we're at this place and in
this moment right now
in our history uh is because we have
lied to ourselves
about what our racial past looks like
and so we have this inflated sense of
superiority
when we look at systems of apartheid in
south africa we had apartheid too
it was called jim crow right so we can't
play that
game of acting as if we're morally
superior to other nations yes we have a
democracy
yes we have freedom of expression but
there's so much that we haven't dealt
with
that we can't begin to heal because we
keep lying to ourselves about what we
are
right right it's issues of the heart not
necessarily
the ego and the money and what we can
accomplish but it's who
we are as americans yeah and um
and people hate to think of it this way
it's not just who we are it's who we've
always been
you